well it's so great to be here today and
I decided to focus my talk on the topic
of needs-based innovation because when I
think back to when I was an undergrad
sitting in audiences like this one of my
more I'd say fundamental misconceptions
was that I saw startups and laying the
groundwork for success as being
fundamentally about that moment of you
know flash of genius as being primarily
about the invention and about the
solution and over time and experience I
think I've really come to learn that a
lot of the groundwork for success is
really late and taking a deep
understanding of the needs of really
building your company of building your
team of raising capital and ultimately
of you know selling your products is
really in many ways grounded in
understanding your why and then building
that sort of through the course of a
framework behind a company so what I'm
going to talk through today is really
grounding a number of stories from
building Calla health which is as Emily
mentioned as a company I spun out of
Stanford Biodesign about five years ago
and I'm going to use that really as the
framework to walk through needs based
innovation so I think of this as the why
the what and the how of breakthrough
innovation so we are going to talk about
breakthrough innovation about you know
revolution versus evolution and do that
through a series of stories from the
company goes without saying please you
know put your hand up any time I'll make
sure that we leave room for Q&A at the
end but likewise you know happy to pause
any moment if if any you know thoughts
come to mind and we'll take take some
time and talk through those so I chose
this picture for the Vista cover because
this picture in many ways to me captures
both the past and the present and the
future of kal-el's so as Emily mentioned
Callao were focused on a condition
called essential tremor so this is a
hand tremor condition that makes it
difficult for people to do tasks that
most of us take for granted things like
writing you know eating soup with a
spoon putting a key in a lock and
when I was early on in my needs journey
these were some of the stories that
really sort of captured my heart that
really ignited my passion as well as
mapped on to on to my my background I'm
a neuroscientist an engineer by training
I'll bring in some stories from
Biodesign I was also I'm also an alumni
of the Mayfield Fellows Program here and
when I think about a woman like this I I
remember a woman just like this who
specifically what she wanted to do was
to be able to make lunch for her
granddaughter she couldn't you know hold
a knife put it in a peanut butter jar
and spread a sandwich you can see here
she's wearing a device this is Cal a
trio we're now a commercial stage
company we have our first product out on
the market just from sort of rough
staging we raised about 80 million of
venture capital we're five years in
first product out on the market and a
pretty exciting pipeline behind that so
you can see here she's wearing this
wristwatch like neuromodulation device
and I'll show you a video in a moment
about how that's controlling her tremor
so before I jump into this framework
what I wanted to do was actually just
pause and show you a quick video that is
a video showing you what this condition
looks like and introducing our product
and then I'll use that to walk through a
number of examples of our story of
building this company so let's see if
this will play so we're really focused
on restoring people's joy through
helping them deal with the symptoms of
hand tremor
people who live with hand tremor it
makes tasks from you know cutting
drinking etc incredibly challenging so
you can see here essential tremor is a
chronic nervous system disorder you can
see for this man here how challenging it
is to do something like spread cream
cheese this woman is a pianist you can
imagine you know how devastating this is
for her from a career lens to try and
play the piano with with a tremor like
that so this is our first product Cala
trio it's a wrist worn device we have
clearance from the Food and Drug
Administration and it's used by patients
on demand essentially when the desire to
have hand tremor relief they simply put
it on as this gentleman is doing here
they use a dose of therapy is about 40
minutes
and that offers them relief from hand
trimmer I'll walk a little bit through
our business model again through a needs
driven innovation model we realized that
today's healthcare system we had to
reinvent putting the patient at the
center of care so we've actually set up
the company to be both a manufacturer
and a distributor so we can dropship
product right into people's homes with a
prescription from their physician in the
science that we really built this
technology from was a realization that
the nerves at the wrists in this case
the median and radial nerve connect up
into a location in the brain called the
ventral intermediate nucleus and that is
the site where implants are positioned
in the brain so I did a postdoc in
neurosurgery I've seen many of the
implantations you put an electrode at
this location and it's like magic
watching the effect on the hand tremor
so we really reimagined that to take for
example someone who's not able to write
and to stimulate on the wrist
non-invasively and restore their ability
to write and really to get people you
know doing back back to doing the the
tasks that they love which for me you
know very much of what drives me is
seeing how we take sort of that
technology in that science and how we
deliver it all the way through you know
really change in people's lives let me
just pause there any any question on
there before I jump into some of the
learnings okay so when I think about you
know what is entrepreneurship everyone
has their favorite definition my
favorite definition is this one a team
of people this is about people achieving
transformational impact in the face of
limitless uncertainty and limited
resources so if you really think about
what you're doing on you know every day
it's how do you see your how do you see
your way through that limitless
uncertainty and limited resources
whether it's in a start-up or a large
organization and a for-profit or a
non-profit this is really about small
groups of people achieving that that
impact and so you'll see when we start
to think through this why what how
framework it's really about figuring out
you know at the end of the day one of
your most valuable assets is your time
because you have passion and you have
skills and you have to figure out what
you spend your
and that's why it really makes sense to
take the time to figure out what is the
need you're trying to solve so that you
know that you are putting you know your
your time into things that will meet
your definition of transformational
impact I would say you know just by way
of background I sat down to actually
kind of write out the various programs
that I've had the you know great
privilege to participate in through my
own education and I wanted to put this
in here really to emphasize that this
content you know can be learned you are
all tremendously lucky to be you know in
this audience today and when you really
think back to you know how can we teach
how can we scale how can we grow sort of
entrepreneurial thinking and innovation
it really comes to some of these
frameworks that we can then apply sort
of very broadly across everything from
you know it startups like I say startups
to nonprofits and academic initiatives
so as I mentioned I'm a Mayfield alum
then when I was at Berkeley for I did a
PhD in bioengineering I participated
there in a management of technology you
nito is the United Nations industrial
development organization so I spent some
time down in Swaziland down in southern
Africa working on medical device
development for in that case Swaziland
is the unfortunate notoriety of having
the highest rate of HIV in the world
during my postdoc I did a postdoc in
neurosurgery at UCSF during that time I
had the good fortune to work with Andy
Grove one of the real sort of giants of
management theory on launching a program
at Berkeley called the Masters of
translational medicine program that
still you know very active today I came
back to Stanford as a bio design fellow
I'll walk you through a good amount of
that thinking today and then worked on
helping start the Excel Innovation
Scholars program and also did a good
amount of work with the clinical
excellence Research Center which is
really around cost driven value driven
innovation in the healthcare space so
this just goes to say a lot of what I'm
pulling on today you know this this can
be taught this can be learned and I
really encourage all of you to learn
what you can train and teach whenever
you have the opportunity
so I wanted to introduce first the
framework I'll take a pot see if we have
any questions and then start to jump
into to learnings on each of these
topics so when I think about needs
driven innovation to me it really comes
down to why or what and how and you can
think of that as being what is the need
that we're solving what is the solution
to that need and then what is the plan
what is the tactics and I'm basically
going to walk you through two specific
examples of those let me just ask before
I jump in the into those now that you
know a little bit about Calla and a
little bit about where we're heading is
there any topic you're just dying to you
want to make sure that I cover while
walking through this anything okay
perfect I'll just jump in and we cannot
take this where it goes yeah okay lots
of those don't worry great yep FDA
clearance regulation anything else
I'm your team great we'll cover that
yeah mentioned the shift towards a
patient centric approach for your
particular application perfect pork and
wins okay
I'll feel free to type up if there's
other ones we should add to that list
I'll make sure we cover those four so if
we start with the Y just to start on an
entirely negative note the reason to
focus on Y up front is because most
startups fail so if you look at the data
you know at the end of the day most
startups don't make it maybe one in ten
or so has a really outsized return and
when you look all the way to let's say
unicorns it's you know maybe 1% of
companies that ever go on to achieve you
know unicorn status so when you're early
in your own entrepreneurial journey how
do you beat the odds and I believe that
really that focused on needs driven
innovation is one of the key ways that
you
can beat the odds that you can set
yourself up for success that you can
give yourself kind of a right to win and
not only a competitive market but
building startups is really really hard
so how I think about this is really
through you'll see in each of these
stages and the why what and how going
through basically a time of me of idea
generation and then going through
screening so for example let's say
you're at the start of an
entrepreneurial journey when I was in
Stanford Biodesign I spent several
months just literally observing
following around any back-office billing
practitioner nurse surgeon you know
patient and their family going through
the healthcare system and just taking
detailed notes on every unmet need that
they experienced during the course of
their hours the beautiful thing about
generating needs in that way is that
everything that you saw that was a
problem was a real problem for a real
person at a real moment in time you know
you have an unmet need if you saw it
then you can go on to actually take
those kind of observations and frame
them up for example into need statements
which takes the form of saying a way to
do something for some population in
order to and define your outcome so for
Calla health for example our needs
statement was a way to reduce hand
tremors in patients with essential
tremor who could not have brain surgery
in order to restore their ability to eat
right and drink you can imagine when
you're then stacking going back to how
do you spend your time you can generate
you know we generated hundreds of these
needs
you can then basically stack rank them
by taking you know your screen maybe
it's maybe it's you know impacted size
of the population times the revenue
potential per user or something like
that you can then screen these needs
against each other so for example within
essential tremor after meeting these
patients after being you know really
taken with how overlooked their
condition was between they they
basically can choose between brain
surgery and then no drug has ever been
developed to treat this condition and
it's experienced by those seven million
people in the u.s. it's a big unmet need
it's about eight times more common than
Parkinson's which is much better known
and within even a need like that if you
have already an area you know that
you're interested in you can even take
that and say well is the need we're
solving the need for safer brain surgery
is it the need for people who can't have
brain surgery to have an alternative you
know is it there and you can start to
compare basically and contrast you know
what is the fundamental and unmet need
that you're solving and so that's
basically how you go through needs
generation and need screening in our
case that specific need came from the
story of a man who I still remember this
like it was yesterday he was in seeing a
neurosurgeon he had just learned that he
was not a candidate for brain surgery
and he was just absolutely in tears he
was saying how you know he couldn't
write a note to his wife he couldn't
have a coffee with a friend he had tried
all the drugs none of them worked for
him because of some other medical
conditions you know he couldn't undergo
the surgery and something about that
really just stuck with me of someone you
know begging for brain surgery and
realizing that you know truly there was
an unmet need there that we could
address so he took that observation of
you know his single experience converted
that into the need statement and when I
spun the company out of Stanford you
know we largely fundraise on recognizing
a need and having a great team of people
around being able to solve that need I
pulled in this quote from Thomas Edison
um if you look if you look at the
history of a lot of great inventors they
truly did focus on needs I love this
quote saying you know I find out what
the world needs and then I go ahead and
invent it Thomas Edison is the inventor
of the light bulb and the founder of
General Electric
so the second why is the second reason
to spend your time thinking about why
it's really to ignite your passion and
that's because startups are really hard
like for any of you already been
Horowitz is the hard things about hard
things it is really really hard and so
you need to ignite your passion you need
to understand your why because that is
what will fuel you know your marathon
these aren't sprits these are marathons
and if you know what need you're trying
to solve that not only fuels you that
also finds the right team because you
need to find the people
from very diverse backgrounds but who
resonate with your why and likewise down
the road to sell your product so there's
a great YouTube video and book start
with y by simon Sinek and that's
actually walking through for example
some of the history of you know
companies like apple and pointing out
that there's a big difference between
saying from a marketing lens between
saying you know we sell computers
they're sleek and modern and elegant you
know do you want to buy one and saying
we challenge the status quo you know we
believe that you have potential oh and
by the way we make computers one of i
won and so it's really that idea of
saying you know how do you actually
start with why and use that to you know
build everything from your own passion
to your team to selling your product one
other thing i just want to highlight
here i pulled in a quote from Henry Ford
with the Model T you know so he really
created mass production manufacturing of
automobiles and he said you know if I
had asked people what they wanted they
would have said faster horses and what I
love about this quote is it kind of
highlights the inherent tension between
the first two points that we just went
through under why which is on the one
hand we're saying to some extent observe
the market right observe what the unmet
needs are take a very objective analytic
approach to screening these and at the
same time there's also just something
about passion and about the fact that
oftentimes people don't know what they
need you know there's there's very
dichotomous views on user groups for
customer feedback groups for really
breakthrough innovation because arguably
people don't know what they need until
you've given them what they need and
then they can't live without it and so I
just want to highlight that here of to
me finding your why really needs to have
both that you know market validation the
sizing the valuation of an unmet need
and just being really true to kind of
your instinct and your gut and your
passion and recognize that both of those
belong and where you spend your time
okay so now we're gonna move on from the
why from the needs finding portion of
this into the what
and I like to call this follow your nose
and the idea here is basically as you
can see here you do needs generation
needs screening then you do solution
generation and solution screening and
the reason I like to think about
following your nose is that when you're
doing something really new when you're
doing something radical
you will hear no all the time especially
when you move into the solution phase so
at a level of needs at the end of the
day most unmet needs are unmet needs
there is a question of how big an unmet
need is but it's almost like they're all
good which one is better when you get
into solutions you will hear every
reason why your idea is a horrible idea
and I think that one of you know when I
think about our team when I think about
sort of what we've built and who has
really excelled in a sort of fast-paced
startup environment to me that's one of
the really key things is how can you
listen to all of those knows and find
who gives the most insightful know who
is really willing to sit down with you
where you can just say honestly I hear
you know I hear your no and I'm trying
to see my way through this can you take
the time to explain to me in detail why
this is a no and then have them detail
it out and poke holes in the theory and
that's where so much of innovation comes
from so if you look at you know our
product Cala trio and to the question
about business model I'll touch on that
here as well when we were delivering our
first solution the product solution we
heard know all the time right the site
of essential tremor is in the brain it
is the you know ventral intermediate
nucleus and the thalamus
therefore to treat that site you either
have to put an implant in the brain or
you have to take a drug that crosses the
blood-brain barrier you know no it's not
possible to do that without drugs or
without surgery and then when we started
to dig in on it we started to realize
you know what actually it's a circuit
it's not a single site in the brain and
by definition that circuit goes out to
the wrist it goes out to the arm because
why on earth can you treat the brain and
have it reduce hand tremor these have to
be connected and so then we started to
think through well based on that can't
you reverse engineer the circuit
so if you can stimulate in the brain in
order to calm the hand can't you
stimulate at the hand to send a signal
to the brain to actually interrupt the
circuit in the brain to reduce the hand
tremor and that's how our product works
so you know now some years down the road
we have beautiful mechanistic data
showing the effect of our therapy in the
brain so it's basically a stimulation
we're trick-or-treating here in order to
treat the brain in order to reduce the
hand tremor but I think that's a great
example of it was only by finding the
people who give could give us the most
articulate reasons why what we were
trying to do was a little bit crazy that
those ended up being our scientific
advisory board members our clinical
advisory board members they're the
people who got sort of intellectually
engaged and saw that through with us
likewise on the patient-centered care
model now that someone asked about when
we got to a point of having a therapy
that we know worked for this unmet need
worked for these patients we stepped
back and said well now we have to figure
out how to get this into patients hands
from our clearance from the FDA this is
a prescription therapy we spent time
with neurologists starting to understand
you know how neurologists primarily
write scripts so for example uh
prescriptions for drugs so we said we
need to fit into their workflow we need
to have a prescription like experience
on the other hand our users our
customers they expect an experience
that's very much like you know your your
Fitbit or your Apple watch they expect
product to be dropship to their house
that they can you know go online to
check information about about the data
coming off of their devices they expect
to be able to call customer service and
then and when you put those together we
really said you know there is not a
current model that works for that you
know you typically can't call a drug
company to ask questions about the
medications that you're taking in the
world of devices typically people use
distributors and we really started
digging into that and saying you know
but why would we want to give our
product to a distributor who then gives
it to the patient that means that we've
just lost touch with being able to help
people through the journey with being
able to you know bring them joy through
that end-to-end product solution and so
we realize
that we needed to be a distributor so we
created a very new model the basically
said we'll be a manufacturer and a
distributor what that uniquely lets us
do is we can inform we educate the
patients about how their body moves I
would say we educate many more people
than actually have essential tremor
about how their body moves we then
assist them with getting the
prescription either by giving them the
information they need to carry to their
own doctor or by in servicing Docs or in
some states offering telemedicine we
then directly receive the prescription
we actually manufacture the company as
well we drop ship product directly to
their doorstep and that and then we
assist them with coming up on therapy
and really learning again how their
therapy through how the therapy works
for them as well as their own unique
physiology I should mention also the
product actually measures using motion
sensors it measures every person's
systemic tremor and then it Tunes the
stimulation to interrupt the neural
circuit for that specific patient so we
already had built into the product a lot
of the motion sensors cloud connectivity
through the base station etc that let us
set up sort of a digital end-to-end
model like this yeah FDA approval was
there anything that you did to convince
yourself and convince your investors the
new solution actually had merit and
actually worked yes so the question so
everyone can hear it was was there
anything before the FDA approval that we
had to convince ourselves and our
investors whether the therapy worked the
answer is yes we have always invested
heavily in clinical science and research
so for example the first work that we
did that was a study run here at
Stanford we showed that we could
stimulate peripheral nerves in order to
affect someone's tremor in order to
reduce their tremor at the time we
didn't know would this be a wearable
would this be an implant you know sort
of I would say we hadn't gone down the
product innovation side of it but we had
a good sense both of the unmet need as
well as of the science that sits behind
that you know likewise we really believe
in accessibility to therapy one of the
things accessibility requires is
reimbursement and so we've been
fortunate to have
investors who are really sort of
alongside us in building the longer case
for clinical evidence value-based
evidence for example to really show sort
of where we sit in the healthcare system
actually on the topic of investors I'll
come to the the sort of diversity and
pluralism and in a few slides here but I
would mention Calla has a very
interesting set of investors it's it's
largely strategic investors and they
actually span across Pharma in
GlaxoSmithKline and Novartis tech with
Qualcomm and Google Ventures and then
medical device in Johnson Johnson
Development Corporation and I do really
believe in bringing together kind of a
diversity of experience and viewpoint in
order to be able to sort of sit around
the table and you know knock down walls
when it comes to both sort of best
practices as well as the big pitfalls of
the various industries great yes
strategy to go direct to the patient did
you experience to position in that
pipeline to say okay you prescribed it
now you have to put it on you can wear
it properly you have to make sure it's
working right from an FDA perspective or
just from a device efficacy standpoint
what we're like major things that you
needed to address there it's really
really great question so the question
was basically in going to a home use
therapy that we among other things you
know shipped directly to the patient and
bring them up on is sort of what what
that means from a lens of the healthcare
landscape from the physician you know
prescriber and regulators so one of the
going back to the idea of kind of needs
based innovation on you know day one of
Callao
we did two things we set up our quality
system and we opened a clinic and that
was really came from recognizing that
the way to test and refine and see our
way through the newness of what we were
considering doing was to have patients
and physicians as our partners you know
on-site every day such that for example
the people who are designing products
could have real sort of interaction with
the clinicians the sites are run like
that as this clinical site is run like
other clinical site you know all
irb-approved studies etc but having it
physically co-located with the company
really opened sort of people's eyes I
think to testing and refining different
business models so what we discovered
over time is first of all to the
question of the physician in that loop
we work we are a hundred percent
embracing of the physicians you know a
lot of our prescriptions come through
physicians who are key opinion leaders
at the major for example movement
disorder centers we just ran a study
that was the largest study ever run in
essential tremor it was a 263 patients
three months of twice daily use we
measure the efficacy by of every dose by
every patient so we have almost 22,000
data points to really mine in that for
example to develop all of the predictive
analytics we do a lot of machine
learning work around you know how do we
identify and treat these patients from a
physician lens it's it's what the
healthcare system needs right we are
able to actually measure how patients
are doing we are able to engage both the
physicians the patients you know their
caregivers and I think that that's one
of the beauties of digital is it is
actually a great democratizer
so when I think about our product
portfolio it's really been about how do
we have few sort of hardware products
you know hardware is also hard so when
have you a few you know hardware project
products few SKUs but actually recognize
that some people would prefer to get
their prescription by being in their car
and jumping on their phone and doing a
quick telemedicine appointment and other
people would rather to go in and see a
movement disorder neurologist and so we
basically said you know both of those
let's let's serve both of these patient
populations and I actually believe from
a value-based healthcare lens you know
to me it's unforgiveable that you look
at all of the the cost curves of the US
spends more per citizen on health care
almost double any other developed
country and yet we drive some of the
worst health outcomes and basic metrics
like maternal mortality and to me you
know we can't spend 20% of our GDP on
healthcare it's continuing to scale and
yet not deliver those outcomes and so to
me it's also sort of a moral imperative
to tackle some of these issues of how do
we sit within the current reimbursement
system you know how do we engage with
the physicians and
we build these very scalable models of
care that can reach beyond the current
system as well great so in a second what
is to embrace ethics and to embrace it
early and often and I love this cartoon
as you can see here someone sitting in a
car is saying if these idiots would just
take the bus I could be home by now but
every single person is saying that so
everyone sits in traffic clearly the
best solution here would be to put
everyone on a bus and it might mean that
they don't each get to be in their own
private car but they would all get where
they're going and when you look at you
know questions like this this kind of
refers back to the moral philosophy of
what people call the tragedy of the
Commons which is the idea of the Commons
being a British pastor with you've got
cows and if everyone has their cow if
everyone's cows go and eat the grass
there is no more grass and no one can
have calves and so there's a ton of you
know different ethical theory built
around the economics of this the
politics of this the regulation of this
and it's really the idea of for example
when you have conflict through
conflicting needs of different
stakeholders how do you address that and
why I encourage you know as you're
thinking about your solutions to embrace
all of the ethical quandary the early on
is it the more time that you have to
kind of see your way through that you
can do things like balance balance sort
of ethical conflict conflicting needs so
as an example for us sort of the modern
day pasture for us is digital health
data and data of around patients and a
great example I think just of you know
the type of ethical topics that we have
always focused on from very early on in
the company long before we were
commercial was things like how do you
balance the rights of the individual
against the rights of the group so let's
say is an individual person where you
know collecting cloud data on usage on
efficacy that really empowers a
beautiful experience for the patients
cost-effectiveness for the healthcare
system etc but it also raises a lot of
questions because arguably as an
individual you should own your data you
should have you know it be protected
privacy wise no one should be able to
sell your day
and at the same time let's say that you
are you know a citizen who has a rare
genetic disease and if everyone else was
required to share their data then you
would be able to discover the solution
to your rare genetic disease if all of
the treatment data genetics data you
know of everyone around you or pooled
together then you know you would be able
to discover that and I think that's a
good example of where you know we
recognized early on that we had to be
very careful about how we thought about
things like an individual's right to
their data and the right of another
person to actually learn what therapy
works best for them so then we could do
things like actually taking the
technology solutions you know talking
about another unmet need to then get
very proactive about how do we build out
the technology is that actually to let
us sort of have our cake and eat it too
that let us you know provide an
incredibly data secure environment for
patients and set up the infrastructure
that allows us to learn you know one
patience type of tremor what works for
them and then actually provide that as
advice to another patient to help them
you know get the most benefit from
therapy so I would just say as you're
going through thinking of solutions
always you know think about what are
some of the ethical questions that will
come up around this you know dig in on
them and learn about them and I know
sometimes think though this is an area
that almost gets a little bit overlooked
so embrace ethics so just a couple last
pieces and I'll open it up for question
I'm so moving from the why - the what -
the how um when I think about some of
the areas that you know there's a lot
that we have not done well when I think
about some of the areas that we have
done well I'm going to highlight two
that really come up there one is the
idea of celebrating diversity and I
think there's a lot of talk about
diversity when it comes for example to
race and to gender it goes without
saying to me that you want to have
diverse viewpoints particularly in the
execution and the implementation not
only the designing your products but the
execution of your company because the
more diverse viewpoints you have then
arguably the broader the market you
serve to put it in sort of raw you know
perspective there's also a lot of
subtler kinds of sort of pluralism and
diversity that when I think back on some
of our biggest challenges as well as our
biggest successes include things like
callous it's at the intersection of
three very different industries so kind
of the the nerve neuro Pharma biotech
world and a lot of what we're doing on
the neuro side we're also a hardware
wearables company we also are very deep
in sort of data science and cloud and if
you think about it when I look at for
example our senior management team we
have people who come everywhere from you
know Medtronic to apples who you know
it's a very diverse team and that's
actually one of the things that makes it
incredibly strong it also means that
people come in with very different
expectations very different backgrounds
I pulled out this figure from a recent
book I've really been enjoying is a
Frederick la Luz reinventing
organization and he basically frames the
leadership styles through sort of a
social evolutionary perspective going
all the way back from you know impulsive
red organizations from sort of you know
tribes and militias and points out that
you know in at the moment of anarchy you
probably want to be red led by a red
leader by someone who is you know
leading from a place of fear or for
example then he traces the leadership
styles through conformism through this
is sort of the commandment control
mentality you still see it in certain
organizations you know perhaps like the
the military the Catholic Church there
is a you know a conformism you see this
in things like school uniforms for kids
as that then moved on into the dominant
theory of today's sort of Fortune 500
companies which has achievement orange
which is the idea of command but don't
control you see this in things like
bonus incentives you know set what the
goals are but then let people act in
their own way let them solve the problem
and then reward them when they you know
when they do that
more recently moving into pluralism
Green which is the example from that
book is comparing a United Airlines and
Southwest
and pointing out that they're very
different in their manuals for flight
attendants we're United will actually
define here are how you handle these
various situations whereas Southwest
took a bit of a different looser around
the edges but basically said make your
customers happy and then put more of the
control kind of at the edge of the
organization in terms of how to do that
evolutionary teal is kind of letting go
of your ego and if anyone can you know
figure out how to really be an
evolutionary teal organization love to
talk with you about that so I would just
say when you look at a leadership style
as a founder it's really easy to kind of
look look at yourself and say well what
is my organization gonna be are we going
to be an achievement orange organization
we're a pluralistic organization but at
the end of the day your organization is
gonna have people who come from all of
these backgrounds especially when you
bridge you know industries and
generations and you know cultural
backgrounds so you really need to build
a culture of respect that actually
welcomes celebrates and build on you
know people bringing their best selves
in order to in order to work together
I'm also a big believer in
strengths-based leadership so the idea
and I can't tell you how many times I've
had you know to employees who when you
actually sit down and really talk with
them about where is their Venn diagram
of what they love doing what they're
passionate about where their skills are
and what the company needs you realize
they just kind of need to swap jobs so
you'll realize that you know one person
is not loving what they're doing and
really wants to do somewhat something
else
and there's another person who's exactly
the opposite so from a management lens
from how you get things done I often
think you know I often find myself kind
of thinking about how can we raise
people to be their best by focusing on
strengths and then looking at that
pluralism and diversity of sort of what
builds a team and what builds an
organization a last thought on this and
then I'll take some more questions is
this idea of self fulness and what this
really is is when you're building a
company it's really hard one of the
things you need to protect is actually
yourself is how do you you know how do
you keep pushing through this how do you
bring your best self every day how do
you keep going through those cycles of
here's the needs here's the solutions
how do we act on this now we have a new
solution idea how can we take that back
to validate the needs you know there's
there's a lot behind doing that and the
ideas selfless is basically if you drew
two circles and you said one is what
makes me happy and another is what makes
the people who I feel connected to happy
and you look at that overlap then that
means you can spend your time basically
in three zones selfishness is what makes
you happy but hurts other people how
helpfulness is where or selflessness to
take it to the more extreme is where
you're doing things that don't make you
happy but do you know help or serve
people who you care about and arguably
when you're in either of those areas you
can you can think of it as you can be a
maximum of a hundred percent you can
either get joy first sort of yourself or
out of out of serving people self
fulness is the idea of selfishness plus
helpfulness so you can be self full and
if you think about it when you spend
time there you can be 200% because you
can get double the joy you can get at
the Toyota doing what you love and serve
other people and just kind of going back
to this idea of you know really
understanding your why building your
team celebrating diversity it's sort of
one of the things I keep coming back to
you of how do you design your life
design your company design your work in
a way that you spend as much of your
time as you can in the you know selfless
alignment so just to wrap up here um we
walked we talked through needs based
innovation the why the what and the how
with the need the solution and the plan
how do you beat the odds you know how do
you how do you beat the odds through
really objective analysis of needs how
do you ignite your passion which is also
find your team you know sell your
product raise capital for the solution
really thinking about following your
nose seeing your way through all of
those noes to find the yes embracing
ethics and then down on the plan you
know celebrating diversity and
discovering sort of your place of self
fulness so that's what I put together in
the the slides and I'd love to take any
questions and I'm gonna check the list
too
if I addressed those topics so let's see
we covered some of the patient centric
care regulatory let me know if there's
any further questions on that how do you
build and find your team and what were
some of the problems we faced I hope we
covered a number of those problems any
other questions
yes having a quality of life centric to
our outcome especially in medicine you
want to do some costs you're doing
something else when you go out and try
to convince people that this is
something that people are going to wines
having a product that's like I'm going
to go out and buy this new thing might
be a little bit difficult I was
wondering if you could speak a little
bit about like having that type or what
do it yeah great great question so the
question is basically about our value
proposition and sort of how we think
about this in essential tremor is
thought of as a quality of life
condition I think at the end of the day
there is a ton of business opportunities
in these quality of life conditions and
yet historically they've been more
challenging from a reimbursement lens
for example so you know if you really
fundamentally start with you know what
is sort of the value of a product right
we are having a tremendous tremendously
positive impact on not only people's
lives but also on their experience in
the healthcare system so if you look at
the two ends of our product you can see
there's clearly good health economics
when it comes to how do you not undergo
a 50 to $80,000 brain surgery and then
on the far other end we are actually a
solution that can take patients very
early in their journey so for example
who are just presenting with hand tremor
get them on therapy and provide
actionable information back to both the
patient and the medical system and so
when you look at today's highly
fractured system in the fee-for-service
world of health care typically it takes
patience you know many different
appointments with specialists before
they get all the way through sort of
diagnosis and on to therapy so I'd say
on those two extremes we really believe
it believe in kind of accessible access
to affordable health care that saves the
system money
and it also as you look at some of the
things like a accountable care
organizations it's also sort of a big
draw from how do you have a competitive
draw into these systems where systems
want to be associated with you know at
the end of day what patients love and so
really sort of when we look at that that
model you know we don't have high cost
drugs to compare against for example
because no drugs have been developed for
this condition but we believe that we
actually have a pretty nice case on that
and we're actively working with Medicare
on initially with Medicare moving into
the private payers on securing and you
know favorable and accessible coverage
yes yeah question for you about your new
generation in the screening process so
obviously you have this incredible
background in neuroscience and I'm sure
that impacted the things that you were
thinking about and the observations you
were able to make when you went through
this process
yeah and so I was wondering if you could
speak a little more about that and also
about you know how much of a technical
background do you think an entrepreneur
needs to have in a certain field in
order to be able to precipitately be
into ideal like you did yeah and what if
you're someone who notices a real need
but you don't have it's still possible
to pursue great so the question is
around um how how do you account for the
fact that often for example I have a
neuroscience background so somewhat not
surprising I looked at some needs and
solutions that sat in the neuroscience
and engineering background and I'm sorry
the second part was uh oh and if you
don't have a technical background kind
of where do you dig in there I would say
I laid them out you know in order today
of saying needs solutions and then the
tactics the how but it's really much
more of a continuum so for example
sometimes when I'm working with the
large companies or presenting sort of on
the entrepreneurial needs driven
innovation type thinking I get asked the
question of well we already have a
portfolio we have expertise in the
following areas we're not gonna go out
and do primary observation in a hospital
and stack rank the ideas and decide
where we go because we need to look at
it relative to our business right and I
think the thing is there
wherever you start on that continuum you
need to do the full circle so if you're
starting at a place of you don't have a
company you can go through the needs and
into that if you start with a for
example what is your technical skill set
or what is your company's product line
you can also start there you can come up
with a solution before the need but what
is absolutely critical if you do that is
that you come up with your own your
initial solution you're flexible about
what it is you then go back into the
need screening and you force yourself to
go through what is the need statement
you take a hundred different variants of
that needs statement you go through a
robust ranking and a checking around
that and you give yourself a space to
slightly modify your solutions and so
often times people you know are not
starting I mean for example the fact
that I came up with a number of
solutions that map to my technical
background that's great at the same time
we were very rigorous about continuing
to assess our needs so that we didn't
bias that too much and I'd say on the
not the question of non-technical
founders at the end of the day I mean
innovation is a team sport so you need a
team that has diversity and that
background and so you know I certainly
there are you know there are technical
founders there are non-technical
founders I actually just recently moved
from our CEO role to our CE SOR chief
scientific officer role when we went
commercial to me that is a perfect fit
for me in doing that and I think that
that's just a great example of it takes
a team and the team changes over time
and that's sort of the beauty of it is
you can learn and you can you know
emancipate yourself from certain
responsibilities and then move into
other sort of areas of growth so I would
really just think about that needs into
solutions is much more of a circle than
you know a starting point in the end we
certainly haven't reached the end we're
back you know in intense R&D again on
the next generation products yes
so you found a solution delivered drugs
for the problem rate for the tremor
drugs already existing revenue stream
from the drug for the device so I think
of electricity as our medicine so it's
just electrical therapy
there's no pharmaceuticals in it but we
deliver it on a prescription like model
that for the prescribing physicians
feels a lot like a prescription oh sorry
the question was on drugs and devices
and sort of where that says so I'd say
you know I think this is a very good
entrepreneurial practice also is we
basically stepped back and looked at the
best practices of all of the industries
that we touch so we looked at you know
wearables and that product experience we
looked at you know Pharma we as I
mentioned its opening the clinic we
spent a lot of time just observing you
know a physician's appointment with a
patient their follow up and that's how
we really kind of invented that business
model as well as that product so the
question is how is it different from a
TENS units which is a different type of
neuro stimulation so we're a
fundamentally different type of therapy
we actually to go through the de novo
pathway at the FDA which is for you have
no predicate devices so I just saved
different from a mechanism of action the
only similarity being they're both
non-invasive stimulation there's a lot
of other you know transcranial magnetic
stimulation etc yeah sure one last
question yeah
so what's next in your pipeline so we
have a ton I'm really I'm really excited
about the pipeline so we're working in a
couple areas so in indication expansion
we're particularly working right now in
deeper in neurology as well as in
psychiatry and cardiology so we recently
announced a collaboration with MGH and
Brigham and women and are doing sort of
work out in Boston as well we also are
pushing much farther on the connected
care experience so now that we have you
know connected devices in the field
we're really kind of be like building
out that full ecosystem around how to do
affordable accessible
of transparent medical care great well
thanks everyone
I really enjoyed the questions